avant d'être une professeure une
chercheuse une ergothérapeute
personne passionnée des aînés leur vécu
de leur expérience de leur sagesse
fine infirmières j'ai eu le bonheur
d'être en contact avec des années dès
mon jeune âge à l'adolescence j'ai même
eu le privilège de passer certaines
journées pédagogiques
en tweed longue durée à l'hôpital du
ville a distribué des collations aux
années
combinée ensuite un travail de préposés
aux bénéficiaires
cette expérience de vie a été marquante
dans mes choix de carrière mais aussi
plus tard dans le choix de mes projets
de recherche
après avoir étudié la participation
sociale depuis plus de deux décennies
j'ai choisi de sortir des sentiers
battus bon ici vous dit peut-être whaou
deux décennies soit c est vraiment
patiente ou soi qui est vraiment
déterminée je vous laisse deviner lequel
des deux mais assez parlé de moi laissez
moi plutôt poser quelques questions
est ce que vous considérez que vous êtes
bien entouré
même après la pandémie
et lorsque vous serez à la rentrée est
ce que vous serez maintenir un bon
réseau social
avec l'avancée en âge le risque
d'isolement augmente le tiers des
personnes aînées sont à risque d'être
isolé manque de contact ou se sentent
délaissés et abandonné
l'isolément peut survenir à la suite
d'une diminution des capacités de la
personne ou d'obstacles dans
l'environnement les années isolé au
moins d'opportunités de maintenir des
relations avec les autres et d'en
développer de nouvelles ce qui peut
mener à un cercle vicieux d'effritement
du réseau social
à la suite de la pandémie les
confinements la distanciation physique
la discrimination liée à l'âge tous à
exacerber l'isolément et la solitude
donc
et c'est triste et on sait que les en
plus d'être anxieux puis d'avoir une
qualité de vie réduite les personnes
isolées ont deux fois plus de risques de
mourir
que les personnes qui sont bien intégrés
qu'ils ont des relations de qualité ça
c'est sans compter en plus lille le
l'augmentation du risque de maladies et
l'utilisation des services de santé et
de services sociaux
donc on veut tous éviter de vieillir
isolé mais que peut-on faire
est-ce que donc on pourrait penser à un
robot par exemple d'assistance qui
pourrait nous aider pour être une partie
de la solution pour maintenir les
situations de maintenir les notre réseau
social en vieillissant
on pose la question bien il savez vous
que plus d'une centaine d'études qui ont
déjà montré que les robots peuvent et ne
peuvent aider à avoir un impact positif
sur le bien-être des années et soutenir
le personnel soignant dans leur tâche on
sait aussi que la robotique et la
domotique peuvent nous assister dans nos
tâches quotidiennes comme par exemple
nous aider pour la préparation de repas
la gestion de notre temps
mais comment un robot d'assistance
sociale pourrait-il nous aider à
maintenir ou à développer un bon réseau
mais pour illustrer sa je vais vous
présenter françoise françoise est âgé de
78 ans
elle vit seule elle vient d'une famille
de trois enfants et elle a eu une fille
elle vit près du centre-ville de
sherbrooke qui malgré la proximité 2 de
commerces et de services est un milieu
qui est relativement défavorisés et où
l'espérance de vie est réduite et le
risque de maladie est accrue gérard son
conjoint est décédé et françoise
contrairement à l'époque où il était
plus courants
d'échanger des services entre voisins
voire de faire du troc françois on se
connaît très peu son réseau social son
environnement son voisinage ses frères
sa soeur sont décédés ça fait deux morts
à l'extérieur bref à la suite d'une
fracture de la hanche
françoise qu'elle le fait un suite d'une
mauvaise chute française vit vraiment
comme une perte d'autonomie et une ride
et au perdu confiance en ses capacités
une fois par semaine elle reçoit de
l'aide à l'hygiène et elle va au centre
de jour mais malgré ces services là et
se sent isolé elle est seule et
laiteries scellé sous stimuler et elle
manque de contacts sociaux
est ce que dans cette situation là elle
est là elle veut pas déranger sa fille
donc elle évite de de contacter sa fille
puis elle a même refusé les visites
amicales d'un bénévole du réseau d'amis
mais est ce que on pourrait à grâce au
robot incité
briser l isolement de françoise mais
grâce à une subvention audace des fonds
de recherche du québec
notre équipe intersectorielle que je co
dirige avec les professeurs françois
michaud et isabelle lacroix ben nous
travaillons au développement d'un robot
d'assistance que je vous présente et qui
s'appelle tea top donc on a tous des
contacts de plus en plus intime avec la
technologie par exemple les haut
parleurs intelligents vont répondre à
certaines de nos racailles mais cette
interprétation vocale 1 et 3 1 sont
insuffisantes pour développer des
relations qui sont riches et
satisfaisant pour briser les vols
isolement
peter peut actuellement bouger tourner
sur lui même bouger la tête scanner la
pièce comme vous voyez peut aussi
scanner des dés les mouvements d'une
personne détecter les personnes détecter
les objets suivent la voir reconnaître
la voix répondent à des consignes
simples en gardant contact visuel il
peut aussi afficher un visage
personnalisé et danser au rythme de la
musique
mais comment exactement un robot comme
titeuf pourrait-il créer des relations
des interactions avec nos aînés comment
cette technologie locke pourrait-elle
évolué pour créer des relations avec
notre france fausses baisses le robot
titoff peut apprendre à interagir avec
françoise donc il faut exposer titeuf à
des environnements réels comme le
domicile de françoise pour lui permettre
de pousser son apprentissage à des
situations réelles vécues dont
françoise et dans un hyper v des petits
tops à développer son intelligence
puisqu'actuellement ils manifestent
l'intelligence qui est relativement
limité
par contre dans notre société actuelle
surtout
contrairement par exemple à des sociétés
comme le japon on a été peu exposé aux
robots donc on est généralement moins
favorable à des environnements avec des
robots c'est aussi expliquée par notre
culture et nos croyances donc comment on
pourrait amener l'acceptation de titres
peu comment on pourra aller au delà de
seulement questionner les uns et sur
quels sont leurs mots leurs besoins mais
les amener vraiment à
agir et à identifier des usages de cette
technologie le et à construire avec les
roboticiens ben nous on a eu l'idée d'y
aller avec la science fiction
d'ailleurs les années ont été les
premiers les premières parmi les
premières générations est exposé à
l'imaginaire de la science fiction
donc c'est tout is est aussi en droit en
gestion en éthique c'est un domaine qui
nous permet souvent on est relativement
on sent moins menacée
et ça va susciter plus notre imaginaire
notre créativité lorsqu'on est exposé à
la science fiction donc s'appeler
participantes de notre projet de
recherche vont être exposés à des images
à des courts extraits de vidéos de
science fiction ils vont être invités à
échanger de façon ludique entre eux sur
les nouveaux usages de cette technologie
le ski va ultime à favoriser leur
acceptation de des robots mais aussi
nous aider à développer titoff pour
qu'ils soient davantage acceptée par les
gens l aelies futur les années
d'aujourd'hui de demain
donc grâce à la science fiction
françois si elle le souhaite et d'autres
aînés peuvent aider à faire évoluer
l'intelligence de quito donc on peut
voir que par exemple titoff pourrait
apprendre à converser avec elle pourrait
aussi reconnaître les opportunités
participation sociale dans son
environnement selon ses préférences qui
top pourrait aussi
apprendre à reconnaître ses habitudes
pour détecter son ennui la questionner
sur ses activités sur son humeur bref
avec un robot qui a et qui manifestent
plus une intelligence on pourrait pour
certaines pour certains ennemis comme
françoise
éviter de lui permettre d'éviter d'avoir
l'impression de déranger son entourage
mais aussi a été stimulée quand qu'une
pénurie de main d'oeuvre par exemple est
augmentée et développer ses capacités
regagner sa confiance en ses capacités
d'interagir avec les autres donc c'est
si ce qu'on poursuit actuellement comme
projet grâce à des années qui ont décidé
de s'engager dans nos têtes dans notre
belle aventure lot de développer la
science la robotique grâce à la science
fiction
donc je pense qu'à la vitesse à laquelle
la technologie s'est développée dans les
dernières années s'est diffusée par don
dans les dernières années nous faire
nous fait qu'on nous porte à croire que
développer un robot d'assistance sociale
grâce à la science fiction a quand même
un potentiel élevé de retomber pour la
société pour la lutte contre l'isolément
des aînés si vous m'aviez dit il y a
deux décennies qu'un jour j'allais
travailler à favoriser la participation
sociale des années en sortant des
sentiers battus grâce à la robotique et
à la science fiction mais je vous aurais
probablement pas cru mais j'ai
maintenant la conviction grâce à ce
projet de recherche là qu'on réussit à
reconnaître l'expérience et la
contribution des aînés à la société et
plus spécifiquement à l'avancement des
connaissances
j'invite j'encourage ainsi tous les
aînés d'aujourd'hui et nous tous les
aînés de demain a osé participer
socialement incluant divers projets de
recherche pour notre santé mais aussi
pour prendre ou reprendre la place des
aînés dans la société
et peut-être qu'un jour vous
maintiendrez un bon réseau social grâce
aux années qui ont soutenu le
développement des robots d'assistance
sociale
[Applaudissements]